hello everybody.welcome as you are
coming in the room please make sure to
mute your devices if they already muted
we're good to go if you have any
questions we have the chat box ready I'm
going to go ahead and share the
presentation screen so we can go ahead
and get started but as we're waiting go
ahead and type in the chat box where
you're signing in from so we can get a
good idea of where people are calling in
from if you've attended any of our
webinars before you know this is kind of
our go-to start of each webinar we want
to see where people are calling in from
so we can get a good idea of where you
all are located and potentially make
some connections if you're in the same
locations so go ahead and use that chat
box and type in where you're calling in
from angela is in Chicago I'll be there
next month for a wedding I'm in Atlanta
personally where's everybody else
calling in from
you
we definitely have a couple of familiar
faces some Udacity webinar veterans I
would call them oh no not share present
okay where else where else are people
calling in from from India
bangalore india all right awesome so we
have some people from the state so we
have some people from India I'm sure we
have some others here and there around
the world so if you are in here today
welcome thank you for joining us we are
going to go ahead and get started so if
you remember or if you were able to
attend the first one or maybe watch the
replay on YouTube this month we really
wanted to share some additional insights
to LinkedIn and so the first one we
talked a lot about your LinkedIn profile
and so where a lot of people tend to get
misguided as it relates to LinkedIn is
they put a lot of effort and energy into
their profile but nothing else and so I
like to equate that to having a really
amazing Instagram bio but never posting
any pictures or never commenting or
liking anybody's posts and so it's great
to have it there but if you're not
drawing any traffic to that profile then
it almost does does a disservice to you
as as a person who is on LinkedIn
because the goal is to showcase the work
that you're doing and ultimately my goal
is to help you all get job interviews
without applying so the way that that
kind of works we'll get into a little
bit further and kind of get in the minds
and the psychology of recruiters and
employers and how you can really appeal
to them as they're looking for talent to
hire for specific areas so my name is
Brett Ellis I'm a career coach here with
Udacity we're also joined with Angela
who's a career coach with Udacity as
well but me parsley my background is in
education more specifically K through 12
and higher education and so I worked
with in career services and helping
students really figure out what it is
that they wanted to do and then also
helping them get to that next level
through personal branding and skill
development I do coaching on the side as
well within my own personal business but
what I really enjoy doing is webinars
like this one as well as in-person
workshops and teaching people about some
of the same topics and LinkedIn as one
of the big
topics that I get requested to speak on
so you're in good hands today so today's
agenda we're going to just very briefly
recap the profile optimization webinar
we're gonna talk about navigating your
homepage and timeline so it's not going
to be just us going through a PowerPoint
today I'm actually going to do a live
demo of LinkedIn as a platform and
showcase to you my thought process and
how I've been able to develop my own
personal brand using that and then
understanding the LinkedIn algorithm so
for those of you who are familiar with
algorithms this should kind of have come
a little bit more naturally to you if
you're not entirely sure what that means
I'll try to break it down and simplify
it into a way that everybody can
understand and we really want to focus
on boosting the awareness of the content
you're creating as well as the awareness
of you and the work that you're doing
we're also gonna talk about strategies
for developing engaging content so as
you're thinking about what should I post
should I write articles should I post
pictures should I do videos I'll talk
about what works and what's worked
personally for me and what may work for
you in particular which is why will lead
into the effective structures and ideas
for posts so I'll give you a couple of
ideas of things that you can go ahead
and get started in creating content for
LinkedIn and then we'll kind of wrap it
up with just a Q&A and closing
statements so at that point it can be
questions about the presentation or just
questions that you want to kind of ask
me about my experience utilizing
LinkedIn it could be successes
challenges or anything and then we'll
just get into some closing statements
but first I want to kind of touch base
and see if anybody in the chat room was
on the first webinar and if there's
anything that you learned specifically
so if you want to type in something that
you learn you can even jump in and share
via video what's something that you
learned specifically from the first
profile piece of the the LinkedIn
webinar anything that you took away
major lessons we really talked about
utilizing your pro
file as somewhat of a portfolio but what
else are there things if you were there
let me know what was the biggest lesson
you took away from that
you
feel free to share via
at or turn on your microphone your video
or we can move on anybody have any
lessons learned who may have attended
the first one
okay no worries so yes like I mentioned
really that first session was focused
specifically on profile optimization and
we talked a lot about utilizing keywords
as well as really rounding that profile
as a living breathing portfolio of your
best work so that employers and
recruiters are able to see the impact
that you've had at specific
organizations as well as works and polls
so links to different projects that you
may have completed or presentations
pictures/video those whatever so let me
go ahead and I am going to jump in and
share the LinkedIn homepage so everybody
can go ahead and see this let me know if
you can see this page right now the
LinkedIn timeline so this is what it
looks like as soon as you logged in if
you can see this let me know in the chat
yes all right Thank You Eileen we are
going to go ahead and get started okay
so really what I want to showcase to you
is kind of my thought process as well as
what most people should be doing as
they're utilizing LinkedIn so as you log
in immediately you're going to be taken
to your Timeline as well as some other
things that are going on on the sidebar
so here on the right side you'll see a
lot of different headlines of different
news that's going on in the world and in
business and education and you know all
these different things and so I
oftentimes will read through these just
to really keep an understanding of
what's going on what's going on in the
world of business and what's working for
certain companies and helps me keep up
to date on things that are going on in
tech as well you see I'm very active on
LinkedIn so I get a lot of messages but
so as you're scrolling through your
timeline you'll see a couple of
different things you'll see a lot of
people that are posting their own
content you'll also see anybody who
you're connected with who's also engaged
with these types of posts you'll
some ads as well which is you know very
similar to a lot of different a lot of
different social media platforms but
most of these people I'm connected with
our first connections which means we're
actually connected on LinkedIn you'll
also see people who maybe second
connections or third connections a
second connection means that you all
have somebody in common that you follow
but you two aren't necessarily connected
a third connection means that you two
aren't connected and you don't really
have anybody in common that's connected
as well so I want to show you I was
looking for an example and this is a
really good one right here so we're
LinkedIn differs a little bit from
platforms like Facebook and Instagram is
you can actually see content from people
that you aren't directly connected with
so this person here she's a second
connection so she and I are not
connected so the only reason why I'm
seeing her content on my home page is
because somebody that I am contact
connected with somebody that I am
connected with on LinkedIn commented on
that post and so because she commented
on that post now I'm able to see her
content so if you think about it as
you're thinking about your own strategy
you want to put out things that are
going to draw likes that are going to
draw comments because then that means
whoever's liking and whoever's
commenting and now their entire network
potentially has access to see the the
different things that you're posting so
this is a really good example because
let's say for example this person here
was a career coach and they were posting
job search tips where they were posting
resume tips or advice for job seekers I
may then say this is somebody who I
should be connected with because I want
to be connected with other career
coaches I want to be connected with
other job search experts so I can learn
from them and potentially collaborate
with them in the future the other thing
that you can think about is let's say
for me as a career coach I post content
and I were to tag Angela who's our other
career coach now if
if Angela is a career coach most of her
followers will probably be job seekers
because they're following Angela to
learn about how they can better prepare
for their job searches so when Angela
comments on my posts in all doulas job
seeker father seemed content as well
then they may say oh I'm gonna go and
follow Brett as well as Angela because
Brett also puts out a lot of really
helpful career advice so that's how you
start to develop a little bit more of a
following and start to grow your network
a little bit more organically than just
going in and sending requests to people
the other thing that it helps you do is
to really kind of stand apart as a
subject matter expert and so that should
really be the goal for everybody in
their professional careers is you really
want to be known as somebody who knows
what they're doing and knows what
they're talking about and for the most
part people have done that in the
workplace but when you have a tool like
LinkedIn it allows you to really spread
that personal branding across to an
international level so there are people
who follow me in other countries who see
me as a subject matter expert which is
something that I would have never been
able to accomplish without the use of
social media and LinkedIn specifically
so that's one of the things that I
really wanted to showcase to you all is
is the difference between LinkedIn and
some other platforms where on Instagram
you're not gonna see somebody's posts
unless it's sponsored or you're going on
your explore page it's not usually going
to show up in your actual timeline so
that's what it is really cool about
LinkedIn and another really great
opportunity to use it for if you're
thinking about trying to become a
subject matter expert in whatever field
that is it may be digital marketing if
you're in digital marketing definitely
need to be using LinkedIn for those of
you who may be in like artificial
intelligence or data analytics this is
still a great platform for you to
utilize because you can once again
become known as a subject matter expert
as you are creating different content
whether that's articles videos pictures
and really getting the word out about
the work
that you're doing because what happens
is if I'm a recruiter
and I constantly see Brett Ellis Brett
Ellis Bareilles career coach career
coach career coach that may encourage
somebody like Udacity or like another
company who's looking to hire a career
coach to then go to my profile and then
as they go to that profile remember we
spent the last webinar really talking
about optimizing this so as you are
drawing people over to your profile
they're seeing it all in alignment this
person commented on that person's post
they are talking about career coaching
they're talking about really helping
people boost their their personal brands
and you can start to see some of the
things from my profile just add on to
that and really strengthen that that
potential trust that that person has
because as an employer there's a lot of
trust that goes into hiring somebody and
there's a lot of risk that they take on
by bringing somebody into their
organization so a lot of recruiters and
employers are doing this kind of passive
and active searching through LinkedIn
versus reviewing online applications and
online application resumes and going
through that some of them are focusing a
lot more on LinkedIn and finding people
passively as well as reaching out to
people who they see as subject matter
experts in their industries so I want to
know if there are any questions so far
because I I know that I covered a lot I
want to make sure that it was something
that people are able to understand so
drop in the chat let me know that all of
this makes sense are there any specific
questions that you have something that I
didn't cover specifically about engaging
with the your timeline
if this made sense just put yes if not
feel free to ask a question and as you
are doing that I'll kind of walk through
some of my personal strategies so as I
am scrolling through LinkedIn I'm going
to be looking for specific people who
are job search experts or people who are
experts in their industry and I'll be
looking for their content so if this
person posts something about a job
search or a resume writing tip or
anything like that I would likely go
ahead and like it and leave a meaningful
comment I'm not gonna go in and say
something like great or awesome or nice
that that's helpful to encourage them
but it's not helpful for you in terms of
also contributing to your brand and
adding value to that person's posts so
let's take a look at this one when hacen
and interview what's the most important
thing young people can do to secure
their financial future as you go through
it shares some advice I may go ahead and
like this and comment and say I would
add to do X Y & Z or this is a great
post the only thing I would add is this
or I personally took this advice and
this is what happened so anytime you're
engaging on peoples posts you want to
find a way to make sure that you're
adding value to those posts and that you
are contributing to that because at that
point that person wins because you're
boosting their visibility you win
because you're contributing to their
posts and coming across as a subject
matter expert and then the audience wins
because they're getting even more
expertise from other professionals in
that industry so that's one of the
things that I really personally love
about LinkedIn is that in my opinion
there's if there's a lot of
opportunities for what I call win win
win
so they win you win and the audience
wins so when you when you take that
approach a lot of people are very
attracted to that and a lot of people
really like to engage with other people
who do that because they know that
there's a mutually beneficial
relationship there it's not so much I'm
typing of a post and
tagging somebody who just has a lot of
followers just to boost the engagement
of my post you don't want to do that you
want to make sure the people that you're
engaging with are people that you have
either been engaging with on a
consistent basis or people that you know
in person or people that you've met on
LinkedIn and then taking that
relationship offline so keep all of
those things in mind as you're going
through and and really think about your
strategy and how you want to approach
using this platform I would say kind of
my best first recommendation is to
connect with people who are thought
leaders in your industry and in people
who are those influencers on LinkedIn so
those people do tend to sometimes have
more followers than normal
anywhere from like you know 4,000 and up
those people tend to attend to posts
more frequently as well so that's
another thing that you want to look at
how often are they posting how
frequently am I seeing these types of
things and you want to try to stay
connected to people who are going to be
beneficial for you it's a little bit
challenging for me because my audience
comes from a wide range of industries
and so my timeline is often kind of
clouded a little bit with different
industries whereas for most people it
can be really beneficial for you to stay
connected within your industry you are
in let's say machine learning it helps
for you to stay connected to a lot of
people who are more so in in that
industry so that your tends to curated
so you're not scrolling through things
that don't relate to you you're
scrolling through a bunch of things that
you know about and that you can actually
contribute to posts and leave meaningful
comments with I do see there's a
question from Eileen is it a good idea
to accept requests from people who
aren't in the same industry seems some
are just trying to grow their network
with random people good question so I
touched on it just a little bit I think
it's definitely okay to accept requests
from people who aren't in your industry
but you you want to think about as
you're accepting this request is it what
is your goal for LinkedIn is your goal
to you know boost your ability to be
found in job searches is your goal to
get
followers as many as you can which can
sum this has been somewhat of my my
strategy because I do a lot of business
on LinkedIn I do I get a lot of personal
clients through LinkedIn so me accepting
anyone is just kind of like a good
business decision in the sense but then
I can also curate my timeline a little
bit so it really is up to you and what
your goals are for LinkedIn I know some
people who personally only use LinkedIn
to learn and so they go in and they only
follow people who consistently put out
good content so think about what it is
that you're looking to get out of it and
then as you're getting requests for
people to connect with make sure that
those are people who are actively going
to either engage in your posts or people
who are going to post content that
you're going to interact with so there's
a couple of different things that that
factor into that but that's a really
good question okay so now we've kind of
talked about the engagement piece so one
of the things that I would recommend is
take some time to do this at some point
in everyday not necessarily Saturdays
Sundays for me I like to get on LinkedIn
during breakfast and so usually between
like 8 to 10 a.m. somewhere in there I'm
scrolling through LinkedIn and I'm
contributing to content I'm also
creating content I'm writing posts I'm
sharing things that have happened but
you really want to make a habit of going
in and contributing to posts and leaving
meaningful comments and actually trying
to engage with people so you definitely
want to connect with those thought
leaders and you want to make a habit of
of helping them by boosting their posts
by sharing their posts by commenting by
reaching out to them privately and
saying I really enjoyed this post I
learned a lot build that relationship
with that person so once you get ready
to start creating content you can then
start to tag those people in your posts
as a way to get their viewers eyeballs
on your content so ok
we are going to jump back in to the
presentation because now that we've
talked about engagement
we're also going to jump into talking
about content specifically so when I say
content I mean you know typing in your
posts which are similar to like a
facebook status update you can do a text
post you can do videos images you can
actually do documents so some people
will upload their resume and post it
there there are a lot of different
things that you can do now and a lot of
these things are new the the video is
fairly new uploading different files is
new but as we're talking about posts in
general I want to share kind of my six
elements of great LinkedIn posts that
have really worked well for me and
things that tend to really help boost
the awareness so getting more viewers on
your posts as well as getting more
people to engage frequently with it so
number one and also just a note write
these down or take a picture screenshot
whatever you need to do because this is
kind of the framework that we're gonna
use as we continue through the
presentation but the first thing that
you want to do is make sure that you
have an attention-grabbing introduction
so as you type out LinkedIn post if it's
mostly text they're only going to see
like the first three lines of that and
so you want to make sure that that's
enticing you want to make sure that
that's getting people excited to read
the rest of it you don't want to start
off with something boring and have a
really long post because then people may
not even read it so you want to start
with something exciting to get them
encouraged to read the rest of it number
two this should really be number one
always always always always add value
anyway anytime that you're posting you
want to make sure that your followers or
your connections have something that
they can take away from that experience
of reading through your posts or going
through and watching your video or
seeing a picture that you put out always
find a way to educate for me that is
that is the biggest thing that has
worked for me because if you think about
it anybody that is one step below you
has something to learn from you and so
it's it's important for you to
understand that you do have a very in
demand
especially within tech you you have
people who have never taken a nano
degree program before who can learn from
the things that you've learned in your
program so always always always try to
add value and one of the best ways to do
that is to educate by teaching or
providing advice tips sharing stories or
create an engaging discussion so maybe
that's a hot topic maybe you're talking
about ethics in data you know maybe
there's somebody's talking about you
know with when you work in data most
people who are not technical have no
idea what's going on so you can really
say anything and they'll believe it so
maybe you're you're posting about like
let's talk about ethics and data science
and then you have other people who are
contributing to that that's another way
to add value so educating and creating
discussions are two of the best ways to
do that one of the other things that
I'll mention is oftentimes you see
people on LinkedIn post I got a new job
or here's a picture of me at my
internship or look at me I just
graduated with my master's degree all of
that's great that's great that's gonna
get a lot of eyeballs that's gonna get a
lot of engagement but if you're not
adding value to that you're probably not
gonna get people who stick with you for
the long run so imagine these two posts
a picture of me graduating with my
master's degree
saying that I graduated with my master's
degree versus me graduating with my
masters degree me a picture of that and
then leaving my top five tips if you're
considering going to grad school or me
sharing the story of how I made my
transition into grad school and why that
tends to resonate with more
now they make hope did he's proud
other things that are going to help me
learn or help me to get to the next
level in my career so you want to make
sure that you're adding value instead of
just kind of bragging and showing off I
think that that's great for personal
branding that it really is what personal
branding is it's a little bit of
bragging but one way to kind of offset
that and to add a little bit of humility
is to brag and teach that's kind of
usually what I talk to my students and
my clients about is if you're going to
brag also teach something that way you
get to showcase your brand but you also
get to educate the next person who's
trying to get to your level which is way
more people than you might think
trust me I started doing this several
years ago on I felt like nobody had
anything to learn from me and I've
quickly realized that that is not true
okay so number three tag active users so
when I say active I mean people who are
logging on to LinkedIn consistently not
those people who are logging in once
every three months to see if they got
messages from recruiters not those
people who log in every three years to
update that they got a new job not those
people who are not on there consistently
and so as you start to use LinkedIn a
little bit more frequently and you start
to engage with people on the platform
you'll start to see who's logging on at
least four or five times a week who's
going through and who's tagging people
who's commenting who's liking who's
sharing those are people who you want to
tag and as I mentioned before this is
it's not a good strategy for you to tag
random people you don't want to go and
see okay this person is very active they
have twenty five thousand followers I'm
gonna tag them so they comment on my
post and now twenty five thousand people
can see what I'm doing you don't want to
do that it's it's kind of an unwritten
rule of LinkedIn and it's it's it's
almost considered like not best practice
for you to tag people who you don't have
an already built relationship with so I
know if somebody random were to tag me
that I've never spoken to I probably
wouldn't go and engage with that content
especially when you start to get very
busy with the platform you're getting a
lot of messages from people you can't go
and respond to every single person so
that's why it's important for you to
find those thought leaders
people who are kind of at a similar
level as you which this entire group you
know these are people who you want to
engage with so that you can all help
each other work your way up versus being
here trying to get somebody here to drag
you up that's that's not gonna happen as
quickly as you might think but you want
to make sure that you tag them in the
posts that you're creating so let's say
for example I posted this is the number
one issue what I see with Udacity
students in terms of preparing for the
careers
I'm a tag Angela or somebody else on our
team who is active on LinkedIn because I
know she's gonna get that notification
go to the post and leave a meaningful
comment now I know that Angela's
audience is going to see my content and
because we have similar work that we do
I may gain a couple more followers from
from her commenting on that post so
tagging people is a great way to get
eyeballs on your post very quickly you
want to get as many kind of engagements
as you can as early as the post is
created to boost that awareness even
further but make sure that they're
active and don't tag random people if
you want to connect with somebody
specifically on LinkedIn one of the best
ways to do that is to try to get on a
phone call a video chat meet in person
or some people that I've kind of done
that with I just made it a habit of
commenting on every single thing that
they do just as a way to showcase to
them I'm willing to reciprocate if I
were to ever tag you in a post because
I'm always commenting and leaving
meaningful contributions to the things
that you're posting cool number four use
relevant hashtags do not be that person
who leaves 40 hashtags on the LinkedIn
post I've seen people whose hashtags are
literally longer than the actual content
that they've posted it may say my number
one resume tip is to showcase your
impact instead of regurgitating your job
description and then 40 different
hashtags hashtag career coach hashtag
career advice hashtag job search hashtag
resume like that's that's overkill at
that point you're trying to play a
numbers game and you're not trying to
create a meaningful experience for your
connections and your followers it
very obvious when people are trying to
play to the algorithm versus actually
trying to create quality content and
using the algorithm as a tool to boost
the awareness of that post it's very
easy to spot those differences even if
you're not familiar with LinkedIn you
can kind of see okay this person has 30
hashtags they're just doing this for
attention so think about that make sure
you're using very relevant hashtags and
not just hashtags that are relevant to
you but relevant to that specific post
so if I was to post about resume tips I
probably wouldn't hatch tag cover letter
I probably wouldn't hatch tag job
interview I would probably hashtag like
resume job search whatever those types
of things because I don't want to
overload your post too many hashtags you
you already have a character limit that
you have to meet that you can kind of I
think it's 1,300 characters you can't go
past that so you don't want to waste it
on hash
but her five readability is key and so I
don't know if I mentioned it but I'm
gonna show you guys an actual example of
this to hopefully kind of draw these
kind of drill these points into you but
you don't want to post on LinkedIn a
huge paragraph if you're scrolling
through any social media platform and
you see a giant paragraph you're likely
to kind of skip over it like oh I don't
have time for this like I came here for
bite-sized lessons I came here for
things that I can kind of read through
very quickly so if you're if you're
creating posts especially long-form text
which actually does very well on
LinkedIn versus some other platforms
people go on there to read and learn so
if you're gonna post something that that
is a little bit lengthy err in terms of
you sharing advice or a story break that
up into little pieces so that it's
easier to read you can also bullet point
to make it easier to read you can use
emojis don't go overboard with that
either but things that are gonna make it
e more easily digestible and more easily
readable to the person who's kind of
scrolling through because if you have
plenty of things that you can engage
with I'm not gonna go and read a giant
paragraph I'm gonna read the ones that I
can get through quickly and leave
meaningful comments and move on to the
next one or things that I can go and
learn and apply write down or do
something like that
so readability is key as well and then
number six is timing this is probably
the biggest error that I see when people
are creating content on LinkedIn and
it's not necessarily an error because if
you're creating content you're already
winning in my book but if you really
want more eyeballs on those posts you
have to be aware of the timing of when
you're creating your content I see
people all the time they will write this
beautiful post hash tags tagging people
pictures video whatever and they post it
at like 10 p.m. on a Wednesday most
people are not scrolling through
LinkedIn at 10 p.m. on a Wednesday or
they'll create a great post and they'll
put it out on like Saturday afternoon
most people are not on LinkedIn on
Saturday afternoons most people will
utilize LinkedIn during their work day
most people log into LinkedIn you know
at between those kind of business
hours that are kind of societally
structured but I know me personally I
spend a lot of time on LinkedIn in the
mornings but for me linked in his world
or its associated with work and because
of my kind of beliefs on work-life
balance I try not to spend too much time
on LinkedIn on nights or weekends and I
know that a lot of people have that
similar mentality so as you're creating
content think about when you're gonna
post so let's say you read a book during
the day and you find something and
you're like this gave me an idea for
this great post you type it up you can
save it to the morning you know if you
if you really want more people to view
it if you want more people to see it
save that and post that in the morning
as you're locking in for for the day as
you're you know you're in the morning
like me enjoying my breakfast I'm like I
wrote this posts last night let me just
copy and paste it tagged certain people
add my hashtags whatever but timing is
very very crucial as you think about
creating content that's going to
actually do well and be more visible on
the platform so let me jump over to see
some content ideas so most of you may
have never posted on LinkedIn I know a
lot of people who do post on LinkedIn
they focus more specifically on sharing
other people's content so that can be
great but it's not doing anything to
build your own personal brand so if all
you do is share articles all you do is
share other people's content that's good
for the people that do follow you but
you're not like
those were care you're branding them
which is not bad don't get me wrong
that's not bad but if that's you all
you're doing you're not doing yourself
any favors by showcasing yourself as a
subject matter expert so here are some
things that I want you to think about
and some things that you can potentially
actually post anytime this week so you
just finished a section on your nano
degree write a brief overview in the
major points you learned tag Udacity and
maybe your mentor or coach so let's say
for example you just finished a specific
module within your nano degree and you
think that thing really really stood out
to me or I knew most of this stuff
because I have a background in it but
this I had no idea about and I learn
this and if those things are sticking
out to you chances are those are things
that other people are going to take away
from as well and so you'll want to kind
of pull bits and pieces and say okay I
just finished this section on my nano
degree program these are the top three
things that I've learned you tagged
Udacity tagged your nano degree mentor
and then maybe tagged myself or Angela
if you've had a coaching session with
one of us about it what that does is one
it showcases two people what you're
working on it showcases that you're
trying to better your skills and improve
yourself as a professional
it shows that you are staying in tune
with what's going on in the tech
industry it shows that you are actually
going through and putting in effort on
these nano degree programs and that
you're learning and taking away things
that you're supposed to be taking away
with if you tag Udacity it can it can
show people who work at Udacity you know
who you are as a student so that may be
appealing for them if let's say maybe
you're looking to become a mint or
something like that um it also helps
Udacity by you know building their brand
and so that's another area where that's
when when when you when you deci wins
and the greater kind of audience wins
and then if you're tagging your mentor
that helps them as well because you're
showcasing this person is a subject
matter expert too and they maybe even a
level above me so you should probably
connect with them as well so that's just
one idea another idea let's say you had
a coaching session with Angela and it
was just really great you had a
breakthrough
didn't know what you were doing you were
kind of stuck in terms of what you were
looking to pursue and Angela gave you
all the keys to getting to that next
level in your career create a post on on
LinkedIn about the things that she
shared with you or your biggest
takeaways or create a story you know
before starting with Udacity I did not
know a clear path within my career as I
progressed through my nano degree and
had a coaching session with tagged
Angela tagged Udacity these are the
things that she shared with me that I
really took away with that again is a
win-win-win you win by creating content
Angela wins by getting probably more
followers because she shares good advice
and then Udacity wins again because
you're showcasing to them that they are
creating a great educational experience
they're providing career development
opportunities for you as students and
once again just kind of boosting that
awareness so there's another opportunity
as you think about content always try to
consider is everybody winning in this
situation and then it's the last example
you finished your nano degree Congrats
show off a little bit but as I mentioned
before if you're bragging and showing
off these things you've got a new job
you finished your nano degree still try
to add value because there are people
who may be following you on LinkedIn who
have no idea what Udacity is or what a
nano degree is and you may be able to
pry them with tips of you know here
things that I learned so maybe there are
people that are still in that same
program who could have something to
learn from you who finished or like I
said somebody who's never done a program
or who's thinking about starting that
program and they want to they just need
maybe like a little boost of like trust
and so you posting that may encourage
them to do that and then maybe tag your
classmates who finished around the same
time as you if you were kind of in
connection with them so those are just
three ideas that I came up with and once
again these are all focused on Udacity
and all focused on kind of like your
progress throughout your nano degree
program just because I felt like that
was something that all of you have in
common right now who are attending but
it does not need to be solely focused on
Udacity or working on an aunt agree
program you can post about really any
that you're doing let's say for example
outside of Udacity you work full time to
take pictures of you know things that
you're working on share different
projects that your team has developed
throughout the past couple of months
share successes maybe you won employee
of the month or you know your team won a
regional award or a local award or a
national award so as you think about
creating content I want you all to get
out of this mindset that you have to
literally sit down and create things
from nothing for the most part the
content that you should be creating is
just documenting the experience that
you're already having so if you were to
do any of these three tips you're not
creating hey but I'm already doing and
then you're adding to it a little bit so
what's almost like I kind of use my
LinkedIn as my own personal like career
journal in a sense and that's great for
personal branding because people are
always coming up to me in person and
saying you're doing so much I see all
this great things that you're working on
in my my response is usually like I'm
not doing anything crazy I'm not doing
anything way more than other person I'm
just better at documenting it than a lot
of people and so get out of the head
like I don't have time to create content
I don't have you know the expertise to
do this just focus specifically on
documenting the things you're already
doing and add value as you do that
okay so I want to go through some
content examples so I actually posted
one today as I wanted to showcase to you
all a good example of utilizing those
six elements piece as a way to really
boost the engagement of the posts so
I'll kind of read through this together
I know you couldn't read but I want you
to see what I'm doing here so today I'm
doing a webinar with tag Udacity on
LinkedIn engagement in content creation
over 1,000 students are likely to see
this so within our YouTube page we
usually get a lot more people view it
than the people who are viewing the
webinar live and so the last webinar
that we did it did get to be over 2,000
viewers and so one that's exciting for
people that's like okay
now I want to read the rest of it
especially if I tag you in that post
that means over a thousand people may be
likely to you know now have a have an
understanding of who you are as a person
they may go follow you on LinkedIn so
it's exciting to get people to start
reading I'll be providing my
recommendations for creating engaging
LinkedIn posts and this will be an
example so I share the six things that I
just shared with you all I broke it up
to where it's easily readable so we see
the attention-grabbing
I'm sharing a list of education so
that's adding value it's readable the
timing was good because it was 37
minutes ago so still in the morning
during kind of people's work hours and
then I tagged people and I have hash
tags so this is an example that I wanted
to show you all that I did today that
kind of hits on all of those areas and
all of these people I have either met in
person had a conversation with or
consistently contributed to their
content and so hopefully those people
would then be inclined to go ahead and
comment on my post so as you can see
this is not even an hour ago and I
already have almost 800 views on this
post now I don't want you to think that
the first post that you create is gonna
get 800 views because I've been doing
this consistently on LinkedIn for around
two years now so I'm still not too
extremely removed from where you are in
the grand scheme of your career two
years is a very short
period of time and so if you can get to
this point within the next couple of
years like that's a really good place to
be and as I mentioned this is just
within the first kind of hour and so
this person I tagged up here and they
went and left a meaningful comment they
added to my list because I asked if they
had anything else they would add and so
now this person's network now
potentially has access to see my post
and since teas a career and life coach I
may get several new followers or
connection requests from people who also
want to see my page in the work that I'm
doing let me show you a couple more
examples just so I can kind of really
get through this point of how creating
content is really beneficial for you on
LinkedIn so you can also create articles
so the things that I shared were mostly
talking about posts because for the most
part people are more likely to read a
quick post than they are to read an
entire article but as you can see if you
go to somebody's profile and they have a
lot of different or articles on their
subject matter area it does kind of
boost their credibility a little bit if
you go and say oh this person has
written several different articles about
career coaching or resumes or interviews
or you know doing well in your in your
job it does add to the level of
credibility and subject matter expertise
so one thing that I want to show you is
a lot of my articles and whoa this
has really exploded and I'll be honest
it's only been because people have
shared it I wrote last year and it
didn't get much traction at all until
around like when and around that time it
started to like really start to gain
traction without me even promoting it
and so a lot of content that you put out
there if you put out really good advice
and really good content a lot of people
are going to promote that for you and
they're gonna publicize that for you and
they're going to boost your personal
brand for you if you are doing something
good for them which is educating them
this is an entire guide on writing a
cover letter that I'm providing for free
I could definitely charge for something
like this but because I'm providing it
for free people are more likely to share
it it's more likely to increase the
visibility of me as a professional and
help people get jobs at the end of the
day so once again it's a win it's it's
more a win win because it's just kind of
two parties here but you could look at
it as a win win win where I win for the
publicity they win for sharing good
content and then everybody wins cuz more
people are exposed to that so once again
this was the post from earlier today a
couple of other things that I've shared
you can kind of see one of the things
that I really like to do is I like to go
to events I like to attend webinars and
I like to brag about other people and so
one of the things that I did recently
was go to a workshop and I tagged the
location I tagged the person who was
facilitating it and I wrote down kind of
my biggest takeaways from that and so
once again that's another area where
it's win-win-win that person wins cuz
I'm promoting them I win because I'm
putting out good content and adding
value and in the audience wins cuz
they're learning something or they're
gaining something from a workshop that
they may not have been able to attend so
okay have a question what's a good
length guideline for a link and article
that's a good question I would say
the shorter the better in most
circumstances I think where you want to
kind of think about what are the types
of articles that people are actually
reading and a lot of those tend to be
lists a lot of those tend to be broken
down very similar to how LinkedIn posts
are structured so ways that you can
engage people without necessarily having
to write just an incredibly long article
it also depends on what you're writing
for us though for me I write a lot more
educationally than other people I'm not
usually writing about my opinions I'm
more so writing about how to so that
cover letter article this is how to
write one how to get a job on didn't
though those kind of just have to be as
long as they need to be but if if it's
providing value throughout the entire
piece and they're learning something
they can take it step by step
writing it a little bit lengthier tends
to make more sense but if you're putting
out like a list or something like that
we all know that lists do very well
we're way more inclined to read five and
here are the jobs in tech you need to be
looking into like those two titles are a
little bit different and creating lists
allows you to sometimes create shorter
articles but I would say if your content
is not super in-depth or link lengthy a
post could be a better option for you
because you're gonna get probably more
views there than you would on an actual
article but I do know that like having
articles that are written well and
provide great value do establish a
certain level of credibility that that
posts don't always do so here's another
another good example and often times you
really don't know how well certain
things are gonna do but I posted this
about a workshop that I was doing a a
couple days ago and this one had 10,000
views and so I'd never expected it to
get that much but that's another thing
to consider about LinkedIn is you never
really know how well certain things are
going to do as another example of me
going
an event and bragging about the speaker
so really just wanted to give you all a
couple of different ideas in terms of
what types of content you should be
putting out and as you saw most of those
things were not things that I sat down
and created it was an event I attended
it was a workshop that I had coming up
it was um you know today's webinar that
I was already going to have to do you a
list of my top six elements that I
already created so I don't want people
to think like this is intimidating also
you have to get out of the mindset that
like I'm gonna look stupid or I'm gonna
look dumb you may that's a very real
possibility but for the most part if you
know something people who were a level
below you don't know that and so you'd
be surprised how many people kind of
take to the things that you're providing
and another thing I would say about
LinkedIn is that people legitimately go
there to learn so you know people are
not logging into Facebook or Instagram
for the most part to go and learn about
the hot topics and machine learning
that's not going on but on LinkedIn that
could be a very real possibility if
you're trying to be known for web
development LinkedIn could be very
helpful Instagram may be helpful as well
if what you're doing is more visual but
Lincoln is really great because people
are going there to learn you have to
think about the different platforms that
you're engaging with and what people
actually use those for so I do want to
provide kind of activity alast just kind
of thing that I want to share with you
all if you're interested so this is kind
of an optional so I want you to create a
post on LinkedIn about your nano degree
program I want you to tag me as well as
Udacity and I'm going to do my best to
actually go in and leave comments on
there to kind of contribute to the posts
that you're creating so it may be about
a module you finished it may be that you
finish your entire degree it may be that
you found at one of the videos really
really appealing or maybe they talked
about a specific company
things that that company does create a
post about that and follow these
guidelines I I would love to kind of see
how well that does for you just to kind
of give you a little bit more
encouragement to keep going because one
of the things that I see with my
students and clients is they get all of
this knowledge about how to create a
good profile how to engage and how to
create content and they keep it all in
their head and then the longer they wait
the bigger they build it up to be it
becomes this huge task now it's it's
like you know I went to both of Brett's
I watched both of Brett's webinars on
Udacity two weeks ago and I still
haven't post and now I'm still trying to
think of things to do you're you you
kind of psych yourself doing it and you
created me this and that's really not
that big so do this today do this
tomorrow if your rewatching the
recording do this right after you watch
the post just as a way to try there's
nothing that you can really lose if all
you're doing is sharing things that
you've learned or sharing about your
experience obviously this is not the
place to talk about you know ranting
about a specific topic you don't want to
kind of take sides or do anything like
that necessarily you really just kind of
want to share the things that you're
going through and documenting your
experience but do this and follow these
six steps and tag me in it and tag
Udacity because I would love to kind of
see how well that works for you and I
just want you to get in the habit of
kind of doing those things as practice
on a normal basis and so as you continue
to think about creating content you're
out when it makes sense for you to do
these things and not just time of day
but how frequently are you gonna make a
habit of posting once a week that's a
great place to start you know for me I
have built a brand on LinkedIn and I use
that very frequently and so for me I try
to post two or three times a week only
posting if it's quality though if I
don't have anything important to say I'm
not gonna just create a post just to
create one I'm gonna always make sure
that what I'm adding is going to be
relevant and valuable to the people who
are going to see it so with that
I would love to know from you all if
there are any takeaways major takeaways
things that you never knew about or any
specific questions that you have as it
relates to this presentation or maybe
even just my experience using LinkedIn
as a tool for my own personal branding
and once again you can feel free to type
it in the chat box or turn your mic on
or turn your video on and chat about you
know the questions that you might have
you
any major takeaways or questions
somewhat related to timing is it ever
worth it to comb through old post to
edit them for value-add or should I
focus more on value add a new post
that's a great question
I think that that's something that I
personally can do a little bit better at
is always trying to think of new things
to post whereas I may have already
posted something before I may have
posted it at the wrong time I may have
posted it at a time that I didn't have
as much of a following I may have posted
it at a time where it was a little bit
too cutting edge whereas today it might
be a little bit better so I think that
there's definitely value in kind of
recycling some of the old things that
you've posted not necessarily to copy
and paste it but to take it and you know
reevaluate it and add to it to make sure
that it is a little bit more valuable
today I think that's a great idea
especially if you can't think of
anything or if you find that creating
content is becoming much more of a task
you can do that but for the most part I
think we get in our heads about like
when we post something everybody sees it
and so if you were to post something
that you posted last March people are
probably not gonna remember it they're
not gonna say hey I remember you posted
this last last March you can't do that
you know what I mean so I think that's a
good idea to do as long as you're
updating it
I will now unsilenced myself and start
engaging more good I hope I hope this
was helpful in terms of breaking it down
and kind of educating and creating this
is not this huge beast that is hard to
take on it's it's good for you to start
engaging more consistently and one of
the things that I would just add to that
is that this is a very slow process
you saw the amount of views that I got
but once again that's two years of
creating content engaging with people
meeting people in person having phone
calls having video chats and so if you
don't get 800 reviews in your first post
that's not that doesn't mean it's a
failure
if you do that's a great success to
celebrate but it's it's really about
being consistent and always adding value
Oh Angela is there a way to be sure I
see someone's posts more often or less
often so you're going to see more posts
in your timeline based on the algorithm
and your engagement in previous posts so
some of the ones that you saw in my
timeline in the live demo those are
people who I'm frequently engaging with
and so there gonna be a lot of people
who are not showing up in my timeline
who I'm connected with because it may
not maybe they do maybe they do machine
learning and me I don't know much about
the technical side so I don't comment
much on that so I may not see their
content as much as I'll see somebody who
I'm liking and commenting and frequently
engaging with so that's one of the way
to kind of curate your timeline a little
bit you can also I think there's an
option to unfollow people but stay
connected I think you can do that as
well
Federico has been awesome
most LinkedIn seminars are exclusively
about the profile now but completely
awesome yeah I I agree most of the
things that you're seeing are focused on
profile and that's usually people's
really their main priority but if you
want to like the entire goal of this
webinar series was to help you all
create passive attention to the work
that you're doing and so the goal is for
you to get job interviews without
applying because people are seeing the
content you're putting out on LinkedIn
they're going to your profile they're
seeing your portfolio and samples of
your best work at that point it takes
away a lot of the risk of bringing you
in for an interview because you've
already proven that you can do the work
and that you know the work and so you
know I keep can't stress this anymore
than the fact that the only reason why
I'm working here for Udacity is because
of my activity and my kind of presence
on LinkedIn because one of the
recruiters there reached out to me and
asked me if I was interested in a career
coaching job and I was and so I think
that in itself is a testament to the
power of the platform and even that
before that my last job I got throughly
in as well so just to kind of share kind
of that personal you know story it
really is powerful and if you are
utilizing it effectively you can
somewhat eliminate that application
process and the job search process
altogether if you're doing this
especially if you're already in a job
that you like you may be getting offers
from people when you're not even ready
to job search which is always the goal
because it puts you in a position of
power to leverage a little bit better
than it would if you were to apply
versus them reaching out and asking you
to so those are kind of my big kind of
overviews I hope this was really helpful
if you did not get a chance to watch the
first one I definitely recommend kind of
watching both of these as a way to get a
more full understanding of how you can
utilize LinkedIn to start drawing
attention to your profile but keep these
things in mind if you have any questions
feel free to let me know if you want to
schedule a coaching call specifically
about LinkedIn we can do that as well
but again I just want to reiterate do
that activity I will make sure that I
try to go on and leave a comment and
because of the following that I do have
it may boost the visibility on your pro
on your post so that's my motivation for
you to go ahead and do it but it's also
just good for me and Udacity as a whole
for for people to see the great work
that we're all doing here and the great
work that you all are doing as students
so other than that there will be a
survey coming to you via email please
complete that let us know how this went
and if there's anything that we can
improve on and then other than that
please stay tuned for some other
webinars that we have coming up check
out our events calendar and see the
things that we have coming up in future
months maybe just bookmarking it we're
still working on the plans for our next
couple months but stay tuned and if you
have any further questions always feel
free to reach out to that email listed
there as it relates to the career teams
and the work that we're doing but other
than that I thank you all so much for
attending and I hope to see you on
LinkedIn
Thanks
you